now gas prices skyrocketing there seems
to be no end to the increase in sight
eight news now reporter sally jeremiah
live near desert inn and decatur with
more on how these gas prices are
impacting businesses and specifically
sally truck drivers
brian i think we can all agree that high
gas prices really do have a trickle down
effect from salaries to products how
much people have to pay to drive has an
impact on just about everything
especially when it comes to deliveries
and experts say there's no relief coming
before the thanksgiving holiday
currently the average in nevada is
3.97 a gallon but compared to a month
ago that's 9 cents of an increase gas
prices are up and that's concerning
mostly all drivers especially delivery
drivers gas is an issue with going out
every day in the truck and driving
around and gas does add to the costs of
doing our business gas costs one of
those things that you just can't escape
you know for business like us we've got
to go on site meet the client james kerr
is the owner of bond security screens he
says when gas prices go up they
definitely feel it we serve nevada
arizona and new mexico at any one moment
five trucks on the road and another five
cars for sales persons on the road and
these are being used six days a week
with all the back and forth their
monthly bill adds up to four thousand
dollars about 48 thousand a year money
they could use for more advertising
higher salaries and product development
we have done some modifications to the
truck so that they consume
less fuel co-owner of grouchy john
coffey says for them it costs about 150
to 200 dollars range per day depending
on the area but their biggest struggle
now plastic cups we're having issues
getting those in stock and i don't know
if that's the issues with the increase
in pricing or gas prices
out here live a couple things to keep in
mind you want to analyze how much you
drive and consolidate your driving also
you want to make sure you're keeping
your vehicle well maintained sally
jaramillo live local now